I think it's been remarkable, um,
to have this level of panic, uh, you know, governor Newsome, uh,
for example, closed the zoos again. Now,
if you're going to lock up every poor child in Los Angeles or San Diego or
San Francisco, so that they're, they're in a little apartment, uh,
they have no space and then you're going to close all the public parks.
Uh, what are these little kids supposed to do? And,
and it strikes me that what you end up with is a public health
dictatorship, which is very singular and how it measures things.
Uh, I had a university president say to me the other day that he will lose more
young people to suicide and drunk driving than he will lose to COVID.
And he said, they're reopening.
He cannot understand why people have any doubt at all about reopening.
I'm Dave Rubin. And this is the Rubin report,
reminder everybody to subscribe to our YouTube channel and click that pesky
notification bell. And joining me today is the former speaker of the house,
the author of over 40 books and the chairman of Gingrich three 60
consulting, new Gingrich, welcome to the Rubin report.
No, it's good to be with you. Exciting.
I'm glad to have you. You are in Rome at the moment.
What's what's going on in Rome these days.
Well, as you know, my wife Calista is the ambassador to the Vatican.
So that's why we're here. Rome actually is at a huge comeback. They, uh,
got in a big trouble back in, uh, February,
because there are about a hundred thousand Chinese workers in Northern
Italy and they were not allowing the flights to continue.
So they were literally flying in for Wu Han bringing the disease right here.
And it got so out of control that their hospital system was breaking down
and they were starting to triage people on the fewer, over 80.
They basically said, you're not getting, we're not gonna take care of you. Um,
he, in fact, Calista helped, uh, Samaritan's purse, uh,
Franklin Graham's operation. They flew in an entire hospital, uh, 68 beds,
60 doctors and nurses into the worst hip part of Northern Italy.
So the Italian government closed everything down. Uh,
we had grocery stores, uh, pharmacies,
gas stations. That's it. If you were in the street,
uh, you had to have a good excuse in writing,
or you could be fined 3000, $200. So for 10 weeks,
Kilian cluster ran the embassy from our house Verde virtually,
and we do amazing amount of zoom and go to meeting. And what have you,
and a pretend weeks,
they basically starved the virus and gradually got it under control.
It's now sufficiently under control that they've reopened the restaurants,
the museums, uh, public parks, uh, stores.
And you see people walking around now,
problem Italy is about 14% of the economy.
$137 is tourism, and they don't have any tourism yet.
So places like the Colosseum,
the last year got 23,000 people a day. You know,
they maybe have 500 or a thousand a day.
That's a real economic crisis for them. But, but, but in terms of the,
uh, pandemic, they are in dramatically, dramatically better shape today.
Yeah. So we're holding this interview for a couple of days.
So I don't want to ask you anything about specifically what's happening today,
but, but generally speaking the way you see the lockdown now in
America, and I'm here in Los Angeles and literally just yesterday,
Newsome put us,
put us in another lockdown and that these things seem to keep continually
happening. We're watching some spikes, you know, it,
it just seems that no one knows who to trust at the moment. Uh,
what's your take about how the States have done it, where,
where Trump fits into this.
And is there something that you would have been doing differently as speaker of
the house to, to push your guys, to push certain things, uh, differently?
I think it's been remarkable, um,
to have this level of panic, uh, you know, governor Newsome, uh, for example,
closed the zoos again. Now,
if you're going to lock up every poor child in Los Angeles or San Diego or
San Francisco, so that they're, they're in a little apartment, uh,
they have no space and then you're going to close all the public parks.
Uh, what are these little kids supposed to do? And,
and it strikes me that what you end up with is a public health
dictatorship, which is very singular and how it measures things.
Uh, I had a university president say to me the other day that he will lose more
young people to suicide and drunk driving. Then he will lose to COVID.
And he said, they're reopening.
He cannot understand why people have any doubt at all about reopening.
And so I would start from there.
The people you need to worry about half of all the deaths are people who are
over 70 years of age and in particular, he go,
the more you go up at 80 years of it's more dangerous at 90,
it's even more dangerous.
So you know that you want to really work to protect people who are over
70 quite. You don't need to really work to protect people who are 13.
Uh, and the idea that we're,
we we've gone from a country that used to know how to open one house, uh,
school rooms and have seven classes in one room.
And people actually learn how to read to an extraordinarily expensive union
dominated bureaucracy that doesn't want to teach.
And you're gonna have this in Los Angeles. They've got it in New York. I mean,
they have a Fairfax County, Virginia,
one of the biggest and richest school districts in the country.
Why would we pay people to not teach, uh,
why wouldn't we have all these big fancy buildings nobody can go to. And, uh,
I think it really raises very profound questions about the whole system.
Yeah, well,
that actually is perfect segue because I was going to say as someone that's a
true lover of American history and has written about it,
and you talk about American history all the time,
are you sort of shocked the way the average American person just sort of takes
orders and doesn't necessarily ask why are these things
happening? You know, at one time it was flattened the curve.
We don't hear the phrase flatten the curve anymore. We haven't heard it.
Excuse me for about six weeks now it seems to be something else or they just
give us an order and they don't really tell you.
Why. Well, I mean, part of it has been,
I think the evolution from a news media to a
propaganda media, so that you have these waves of coverage, uh,
I compared it to, uh, watching the fledge Alante in the middle ages,
this was a group that would go from city to city beating themselves.
And so you have all of these people out here who they panic. Um,
now the truth is, if you look at the death rate, there was no reason to panic.
Uh, this is not the bubonic plague. It's, it's not Ebola.
Uh, most people who get, first of all, an amazing percentage who get the,
um, the, the, by the Chinese virus, which is what it is.
Most of them don't even know. They have it. Um,
when you're as old, somebody tested positive who was quote asymptomatic,
that means whatever symptoms they had were so mild that
it didn't affect them. So you have to stop and say, wait a second,
why are we panicking over people? You know,
the numbers go up with the numbers,
go up with people under 35 who are totally healthy. Uh,
and I think the, I, I have been truly appalled by my younger daughter,
J bushland as a certified financial analyst and used to run a very large budget,
billion dollar plus budget.
And she said to me that night and just sheer discussed, she said,
I have never seen statistics put together so badly that it is
impossible to know what's actually happening.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.